now the interesting question is why why
spelling is worthwhile to begin with
English is a very strange language in
that way English is you know somebody
had the idea this is a if you're a
language designer like me this is a this
is a kind of a little
story you always you always know which
is somebody had the idea back in the
what 1600s maybe that you would add some
letters to words like debt as a famous
example you put that b in there to
represent that that's really something
that corresponds to the Latin word
debiture but it's a really bad idea it
was a really bad design mistake to add
these letters in that represented where
the word might have come from in another
language but which are not pronounced in
the in the language that you're dealing
with it's a it's a it's a good example
of a language design mistake in any case
this is a this is a small example of a
of a growing hypograph so this is this
is just showing oops it's just showing
starting from an initial hypograph there
we're just showing the successive steps
and the growth of this thing and you can
see different uh well here let's make
another example here let's take an
example where it actually grows into
something that you would recognize so
here's a here's a hypograph that's kind
of growing just rewriting itself if you
run it a bit longer and then you render
it nicely it looks like that
so in other words that that underlying
hypergraph it's the the pattern of its
connections is such that a sort of
reasonable human rendering of it would
make it look like that and when you sort
of measure its properties you will
discover that this is a a
somewhat curved space so that's that's
kind of that's kind of how that works
and and you can see I mean there are
many oh gosh you can get all kinds of
different different forms
um in the I mean this is like the first
well maybe 10th minus 100 seconds or
something of the universe might look
like this but it starts looking very
very different from that very quickly
but these are different possibilities
these are essentially different rays and
real space corresponding to different
particular rules which you're picking in
this ruly ad and the the question of
which rules you pick
you are an observer who is also
operating according to certain rules and
so the question of which rules you pick
in the end does not matter but the this
is for purposes of us understanding
what's going on we're sort of picking a
basis in which to look at things and
those are examples of what happens in
those cases
that did that was that what you were
looking for I mean
so how can I get used from that that if
I run it long enough I get the end time
equations where do I pull the Einstein
equations out there there's a there's a
book that I think there are copies of
here that's about 800 pages long that
has the beginnings of that and there's a
bunch of papers by one of my young
collaborators that have a lot more
detail on that
um the the uh there's not there's not a
trivial thing okay it's I can't give you
the the instant um instant version of it
which is not too surprising but but um I
mean I could give you some indication of
how things work let me see if I can show
you one thing here so first question is
what's the dimension of the what's the
when you have some complicated thing
like this what is the effective
dimension of space to which this
corresponds and so you can at least get
a sense of that by seeing that imagine
that you start at one point in that
hypograph and you move one graph
distance away at every step you build up
a a ball and that ball has a number of
nodes in it that grows in some way if
you if that number of nodes grows like R
to the D where R is the distance out you
go in the ball then D gives you an
estimate of the effective dimension of
the Continuum limit object the next
order correction to that is the
curvature richly Scala curvature is the
thing that appears as the first order
correction and so when you look at if
you look at the growth rate of um let's
see is that one of those that here this
is an example that's that curved space
you actually see that it gets to be well
roughly a two-dimensional surface but it
has a variation from that that variation
corresponds to the presence of Richard
curvature in the effective Continuum
limit space that comes from this object
and so that's the beginning the Einstein
equations conveniently happen to contain
the Richie scalar and the rich utensa
and the the beginning of this is you
start deriving the rich utensa by
looking at these growth rates of of
balls in these typographs that's that's
the beginning of how it works it's kind
of the the the the the structure of the
derivation is actually not that
different than the derivation of fluid
dynamics from from molecular Dynamics
which by the way I should say it is not
something that people have been trying
for 100 years to get a rigorous
mathematical derivation of fluid
dynamics from molecular Dynamics that's
a very hard thing I think actually I
made some progress recently by thinking
about computational irreducibility and
things like this but that's the the
mathematical eyes and T's are definitely
not crossed and what we have to do
involves taking more limits and more
elaborate things and the mathematics
really doesn't doesn't quite exist to
get sort of the but we can it turns out
that many approaches to mathematical
physics that people have taken whether
it's spin networks probably String
Theory as well probably a causal set
theory a bunch of other approaches plug
in very beautifully to what we've done
so what we've done is kind of a concrete
version of things to which those are
various kinds of approximations so you
can kind of triangulate in on what you
see now it turns out that my one of my
young collaborators a trap called
Jonathan gorod just recently I think he
hasn't published this yet but but I've
been we've been actually simulating
space-time starting from the this
underlying discrete space And then
trying to get a large enough number of
nodes in this underlying discrete space
to make something that is a good
approximation to actual physical space
and so you can actually compute black
hole collisions in this in this
underlying in this thing which is just
made of discrete atoms of space and the
results are very good and the thing that
is sort of interesting usually when you
compute black hole collisions you start
from the Einstein equations continuous
partial differential equations and then
you discretize them you put them on a
computer
et cetera Etc et cetera and when things
you get all upset when there's a
numerical analysis glitch and something
you know it mattered how you did the
discretization then that's considered
bad when you're starting from the
continual mindstein equations when we're
starting from these discrete underlying
systems and we come up then for us
finding a numerical glitch is totally
thrilling because it will allow us to
actually see through to the to the
essentially atomic structure of space
um and so the the thing that is the
challenge for right now is you know
Brownian motion was the thing that
really finally convinced people I think
that molecules exist it was an effect
that had been seen 100 years earlier
people didn't know what it was and the
question is what the corresponding
effect is that probably has already been
seen in physics maybe a hundred years
ago that is the thing that is the clue
that shows that in fact space-time is
discrete my current guess actually is
that it would turn out the dark matter
is exactly that and having just made a
big study of the second law of
Thermodynamics you may know from the
history of the second North
thermodynamics one of the things was
people used to believe that heat was a
fluid that heat was a fluid that
suffused substances and that that's how
that worked because they had no other
kind of way of thinking about what heat
might be that was the caloric theory of
heat that turned out to be wrong it's
heat is actually associated with
emotional molecules and things my my
current little aphorism is dark matter
is the caloric of our times that is it's
something which is where people describe
it into of particles but that's just not
right it's some other some other feature
of what's going on underneath you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy